Hyundai is planning a new electric vehicle manufacturing plant in the U.S....
...with discussions about building a facility in Georgia...
...near the South Korean automaker's existing plants.
Hyundai confirmed it would announce a plan soon.
The Biden administration has been pushing for more investments in EV production...
...and related suppliers to create jobs and drive a clean energy agenda.
It says it will allocate more than 3 billion dollars in infrastructure funding...
...to help make good on its pledge for half of the vehicles...
...sold in the United States to be electric by 2030.
In April, Hyundai announced a 300-million-dollar investment...
...to manufacture all electric and hybrid vehicles at its Alabama plant.